the past the successful school reform is
that of what I call little large school
reforms it starts with a simple premise
those responsible for doing the work
should be empowered to do the work when
I was hired to teach high school in
Baton Rouge Louisiana I offer to pick up
a set of intro economics textbooks get a
buck a pound of the book sale I got
admonished for asking the question
before I filled out the requisite
paperwork this is daily life for far too
many of our nation's features before
they can even focus on solving problems
for kids they have to live in fear that
they're going to get in trouble for
trying to be smart about how they're
serving kids better the solution really
is the path of little our reform we need
to rethink systems and policies so that
those asked to serve and educate kids
are empowered to make the decisions they
need to make and then held responsible
for the results it might be more
frustrating to trust educators in
communities across the land but it's a
lot more successful than promising
they're leaving that authority with
self-important officials whether they
work in the federal government or some
big dollar foundation to learn more
about my take on the promise of little
our reforms check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a TI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds